congratulations y'all come on
I gotta ask who's kissing your arm
tonight uh you know there's been several
culprits up there she was one of them
let's go with that there's a lot of love
in this cast huh yeah I believe it yes
That's Amore
I heard some hooting and hollering back
there who's the loudest who's who is the
most hyped about the swim hey Haley
Haley Lou Richardson I have to corporate
across the board today yeah she's the
noise leader yeah what was your reaction
when you heard them call the White Lotus
God it just felt so good oh yeah you
guys deserve it thanks and if we do it
for the awards right
I mean it's kind of fantastic that this
Ensemble consists of so many people from
across the globe and I mean you guys all
showed up tonight I mean there's 22 of
y'all I mean
the friendship's gonna continue long
once the show is done oh for sure oh for
sure yeah Sabrina and patchatore is in
my life forever homina not going
anywhere yeah how about you sir yes hey
I mean there's some really amazing
people in here you can see me like you
had fun filming it and now you get to
celebrate being sag award it was fun
yeah yeah how are we celebrating tonight
we're gonna just eat some pizza take it
down real Italian style yeah that's
right that's the main plan I'm Gonna
Leave You too oh by the way you and
Jenna Ortega up there I think we need a
buddy cop comedy or something I'm down
we'll just kill everybody with our eyes
whose idea was that uh no I don't know
okay but you went with it you guys
crushed that we went with that
lady you guys congratulations
[Music]